[Music]
I'm sorry chicken and I'm the chairman
of the Shotley heritage peer project the
short leap here is over and I'm 22 years
old most local people would love to be
able to walk on it go fishing crabbing
and board boats what it was built for in
the first place
volunteers not see crucial we have no
paid staff at all at the moment and we
hope to employ people in the future it
was vital from the very beginning the
Baber and this account for got involved
and we were very fortunate because they
paid for a survey and decided with us
what was the best way forward I broached
with my colleagues the possibility of
the council buying the pier but we
reckoned it would not fit in with our
strategy basically we can't just keep
putting money where we'd like to and
when a group encouraged by Derrick Davis
was set up locally to buy and restore
here we were very much supportive of
that it's obviously a project which is
going to benefit the community when it's
when it's completed it will be somewhere
where people can enjoy themselves for us
also it will help to raise the tone of
the whole foreshore and that is in the
interest of well that as a
administration it's also in the interest
of the local community our group is
certainly an exemplar at every stage
we've talked the Baber and kept them
involved with what we're aiming to do
and I think that's the lesson I would
pass to other groups is talk food the
district councillors talk to the
officers because they are listening and
they do want what's best of a bur and
our area and to have that support and
the kind of expertise on how to fly to
grow and how to bid for things that has
helped us secure the first hundred
thousand pounds that we need we did get
an economic development grants of 20,000
pounds from Baber to help us develop the
plans I would like to say thank you too
baby you're doing a fine job liaison
with us and keep up the good work
we're in the grounds of Bentley's first
cooperative pub have raised a hundred
thousand pounds and we have built a shop
which is now run by 45 volunteers from
all aspects of the village the store is
volunteers all the people serving all
the people buying everybody as a
volunteer it was needed because eleven
years ago our village stall closed and
we've had nothing since paper District
Council have been exceedingly helpful
their community team helped us through
the process of getting a capital grant
from Weber they also identified the
princes countryside fund which was the
catalyst money that arrived and we were
able to start work in February and open
in July so we have been greatly helped
by the community team at Weber without
it I would probably be still standing in
a car park waiting for the rest of the
funding I would like to express my
thanks to the Babel communities team for
all their help and advice which has
proved vital in our bid to open a
community shop we had a really tall in
West thought which had served its
purpose was been here since 1978 and it
was in fairly sorry state and that was
really what made us start to think can
we raise the money to build a new
village hall without the volunteers we
wouldn't be here the village hall
committee has done a tremendous amount
all voluntary the project manager and
architect has given all these time for
free but then so have lots of other
people out of the village you know we've
had a lot of help from other
organisations lots of advice lots of
support the counts have been fantastic
from very early on we made a
relationship with them they've advised
us all the way through lots of different
departments have come out and talk to us
or spoken to us on the phone we've met
with them
and we've also had a substantial grant
from mid Suffolk District Council the
offices have been various available to
us all the way through they've been very
very good in all aspects that we've
needed to deal with and they advised us
on applying for grants to other
organisations but we had a big grant
from the mid Suffolk District Council
which totaled twenty five thousand
pounds
that was apart from the help we've had
from our district counselor and the
county counselor it was it was an honor
but also it was fairly easy you've got
one side one hand which has got very lot
of talented people who have moved into
Westhoff village where the architect
there's a landscaper and that's where it
started on the other hand upstairs here
you've got a dedicated and a very
efficient community team and the
planning officers as well who has has
gopher planning so they have to be
involved as well so you've got those two
things it's really like two hands we put
them together you pray for a start and
then you see you open them up and you
see what comes down it's been rebuilt by
the village by the community they were
very very good at using their local
talents it is absolutely wonderful as an
example to us all and many many villages
that are now looking towards doing the
same we'd like to say a very big thank
you for everything you've done for us
and the support in all kinds of areas
that you've given us throughout this
project and of course for the financial
help which has made a big difference
thank you very much
you
you
[Music]